PROFESSOR: It's
time for step two.
What don't we know here?
Well, we don't know anything
about the state correction.
So n1, what is n1?
So step two is find the
piece of n1 k, the piece that
is in the space v hat.
So I will use this
notation, a bar here,
saying, of this vector,
the piece in that subspace.
Then we, of course,
need to find the piece
in the degenerate subspace.
Remember, the corrections
are orthogonal
to the original state,
but the corrections
can have a piece on vn.
The vn has more states.
So it can have a piece on vn,
and that's typically the part
that is a little hard to do.
So what do we do here?
We take the order one
equation, lambda equal 1,
and we hit it with p0.
So we'll hit with p0 on
the order lambda equation.
So think of the p0 vector,
bra, appearing here.
We know the energy of it, so
this will become a number.
So we get Ep0 minus En0 p0 n1 k.
And indeed, when you
see here-- you say,
oh, this is my unknown.
I don't know the first
order correction,
and I'm getting the components
of this unknown correction
along the v hat space.
That's why this calculation
can only give me
the piece of n1 k along v hat.
And then, what do we have here?
We have p0 Enk1
minus delta H n0 k.
It's just that order one
equation calculated here.
So what is it?
You recognize the
challenge here is always
sort of trying to remember what
the symbols mean and simplify
things.
So for example, here.
This is a number.
So what you must ask
is whether this vector
is orthogonal to this
one because you're
going to get an inner product.
And this is a vector
in v hat, and this
is a vector in v capital N. So
therefore, they are orthogonal.
So this term vanishes by
orthogonality of these two.
On the other hand, we are
left with this part here.
Now, that's a matrix
element of delta H
between a degenerate state
and the rest of the states.
So that's something
you have to calculate.
There's no way around it.
So we use our notation.
And in our notation,
this will be delta Hpnk.
All right.
So this gives us--
we're done with this equation.
It was simple.
No big sweat.
We now have these coefficients,
because these are numbers,
and we can just
divide over here.
And this factor is
nonzero because all the p
states that are in v hat
have different energy
from our degenerate ones.
So there are the
components of this.
So we have p0 n1 k is equal
to minus delta Hpnk divided
by this quantity, Ep0 minus En0.
And therefore, we
can write n1 k.
If you have the inner products
of a state with p arbitrary,
the state is the sum of other
p's times that inner product.
So I'll write it as minus
because of that minus here.
The sum over p of delta
Hpnk over Ep0 minus En0 p0
written like that.
This is something-- maybe
it sounds a little fast,
but if you have a basis
vector, alpha i with psi
being the number
beta i, the state
psi is equal to the
sum of beta i alpha i.
Once you have the
components, the vector
can be reconstructed as the
components times the basis
vectors.
So that's what we did here.
We have the components here.
And therefore, the
vector is the components
times the basis vectors.
You can check that.
If that makes you
a little uneasy,
just put the p0 here,
and recalculate that,
and you will get that answer.
Now, as written it there,
it's really not precise.
You're making,
technically, a mistake.
This equation is technically
wrong because that's not n1 k.
That is only the components
of n1 k along v hat.
So this is v hat.
If n1 k has something along
the degenerate subspace,
we haven't found it.
But this much we found.
We've found part
of the correction.
So degeneracy is always
a complicated thing.
So we're going to try to find--
we're going to
find, in fact, now
the component of the correction
around the degenerate space.
Now, in nondegenerate
perturbation theory
we manage to use this equation
to calculate fully the state.
But now we've used this
equation all the way.
We put states in the
degenerate subspace,
and we found the energies.
We put, in the other
part of the space, v hat,
and we found the part
of n1 along v hat.
And we ran out of things
from that order one equation.
It has no more information.
So somehow it must be that the
next equation that we usually
need to go to second
order in energy
will tell us something about
the missing part of n1.
So that's the surprising thing.
You have to go to order lambda
square to find the first order
correction to the degenerate
part of the state.
That's why degenerate
perturbation theory
is famous for its complication.
You really need to go pretty
high to find the things.
So let's do it.
So this is step 3.
You hit the order lambda
squared equation with n0 l.
And therefore,
the left-hand side
is going to be 0 because that
operator on the left-hand side
always kills those states.
Now, you could have been
a little sloppy here.
I was sloppy when I first
solved those equations.
I didn't say, OK, this is v hat.
I said, that's the answer.
That's the whole state.
There's nothing along
the degenerate subspace.
But then, if you stop
there, you can live happily
the rest of your life.
But if you go to
the next equation
and find that it's
wrong, there was a piece
along the degenerate subspace.
So let's see that.
So we'll also write,
as we've started to do,
n1 k being equal to n1 k along
v hat plus the piece of n1 k
along the vn.
And this one we got.
And this one, well, is it there?
Do we need it?
Does the state
receive a correction
in that space or not?
Well, let's do the work.
Let's hit this
with those states.
So what happens?
We have n0 l Enk 1
minus delta H n1 k.
That's our term there.
Actually, I will write it twice.
So I'll copy it again.
n0 k l Enk 1 minus delta H n1 k.
Why do I copy it again?
Because I'll just put
here on v hat and on vn.
So it was one term with an n1 k.
But you know, the
n1 k vector has
components along two subspaces.
And therefore, we might as
well put each one separately
so we can think about
them in a clear way.
Then, what else?
There's one more
term, the En2 k.
And that is relatively
simple because that's Enk 2.
And then we have the overlap
of an n0 l with an n0 k which
is a delta lk.
So this whole thing must be 0.
That was the right-hand
side of the equation.
But the left-hand side of the
equation was 0, so that's 0.
OK.
So now we have to think
about these terms.
What do we know?
What is 0 to begin with?
What is not 0?
This term in here,
we know n1 k already.
We found it there.
So that's nice.
We know n1 k.
We know this corrections.
But this is simpler because n0
l is in the degenerate subspace.
This is a number, and this is
in b hat, so that's 0 again.
OK.
So that's a simplification.
Here we have a very
interesting situation.
We have the delta H, and
we have this basis state
of the degenerate subspace.
We know that delta H is diagonal
in the degenerate subspace,
but is this n0 l an
eigenvalue of delta H?
Not quite because
being diagonal,
these basis vectors
make delta H diagonal.
So delta H is diagonal
in this subspace,
but doesn't mean this thing
is an eigenvector because it
can give you something outside
the degenerate subspace.
So we cannot quite just say
that the eigenvalue of this is
the first energy correction.
But actually, we can.
Let me explain that.
So let's look at
this term alone.
With this term alone-- now
this time I cannot kill this
constant because this is
in the degenerate subspace,
and this is in the
degenerate subspace.
So we will have
to deal with that.
So let's do this.
So output here.
n0 l delta H n1 k.
We're going to try
to simplify this.
And the way to do it--
this is n1 k, very
important in vn--
is to insert the resolution
of the identity here.
So I'll do it.
We'll put n0 l delta
H, and now we'll
put the whole resolution
of the identity.
So we'll put the sum over q n0
q n0 q plus a sum over p p0 p0,
all acting on n1 k of vn.
I actually want
to remark that all
what I'm doing in this line--
so let's break this.
The equation was up to
here, and we decided
to try to understand this term.
So we're trying to
understand this term.
Just that term.
Now, delta H here is
acting between degenerate
eigenstate here and here,
some arbitrary state
in the degenerate subspace.
So we go here and we
say, OK, since this
is in the degenerate subspace,
this inner product with vector
in v hat, this is 0.
So that part of the
resolution of the identity
is not relevant.
If that part of the
resolution of the identity
is not relevant, we are
left with n sum over q n0 l
delta H n0 q n0 q times n1 k vn.
And now you can use that
this matrix is, indeed,
diagonal in the
degenerate subspace.
And therefore,
this matrix element
is the energy Enl 1, the
first order correction,
times a delta lq.
And then we can
do the sum over q
because there is a
delta function here.
And this becomes
Enl 1 n0 l n1 k vn.
So this is very nice.
It took us a little bit of work
but look what has happened.
This delta H term is going
to become the same structure,
n0 l n1 k overlap.
So it's great progress.
So what does our
equation become?
Well, from the first
term, this is the rest
of the end of the aside.
From the first term
we have minus n0 l
delta H n1 k in v hat.
That's all that was left
from that first term.
And this term is
known because n1
is known along the rest
of the Hilbert space.
The second term over there
that was giving us trouble
has become something
very simple.
It has become Enk
minus Enl, both 1,
multiplied by n0 l n1 k.
I could put this vn, or
now I may not put it either
because I am already
projecting to a state
in the degenerate subspace.
So I am finding the component
along the degenerate subspace.
So even if n1 k had
a piece along v hat
it would drop out here.
So it's completely legal, and
it's simpler to erase the vn.
And then the last term is still
there, plus Enk 2 delta lk
equals 0.
OK.
This is our master equation.
After thinking of this
equation for a while
and using our properties,
we got this far.
It's a very nice equation.
It does give you the
second order energies.
We were looking for
the part of the state
along the degenerate subspace.
This was our main unknown.
But still, we can
get the energies.
Why?
Because we can take l
equals to k, in which case
the term that we don't know
drops out, because nl equals
to k, these things cancel.
So when l is equal to k we get
that Enk 2, the second order
correction to the energy, is
n0 k delta H n1 k in v hat.
That's it.
That's your second
correction to the energy,
and that's very nice.
Why do we say that's it?
Because we actually
have the answer for n1.
So we can find the
complete formula for this.
I'll write it here.
After a couple of
steps of algebra
this gives minus the
sum over p delta H
nkp over Ep0 minus En0 squared.
Look at that formula.
It has the same form as
the second order correction
to nondegenerate states.
Same look, except
that you only sum over
the states that are outside
the degenerate space.
It was exactly of this form the
second order energy correction.
So it's kind of nice and simple.
But let's look at
this equation again.
And here is the thing that
would have been shocking
if we didn't do this right.
If we had set l different from k
here, if l is different from k,
then this term is 0.
If we didn't think--
if we hadn't suspected
that the state n1 k had
a piece along with
the generate subspace,
we would have not
introduced it, and we
would have had not this term.
And the equation
would have become
this equal to 0, which is 0.
You have there n1 of k.
And you can look at it,
and look at it for hours,
and it's just not 0.
So unless we have this
piece, the equation
doesn't make sense.
So this proves that the state
must develop a component
along the degenerate subspace.
And let's now finally get it.
It's just one line
at this point.
We don't have to do much.
So when l is different from
k, l different from k--
so what do we get
for the equation?
Look at it there.
We can solve directly
for the piece n0 l
n1 k is equal to-- solve
for the second term.
The other term goes on
the right-hand side.
So n0 l delta H n1 k
over Enk 1 minus Enl 1.
And here is another thing
that ended up working well.
If the degeneracy
had not been broken,
we're doing l different from k.
If some of these
would have been 0,
this would give you
0 in the denominator.
This wouldn't work out.
So it was urgent here
that all the degeneracy
had been broken to first order.
Otherwise, you couldn't have
computed this state this way.
This means that n1 k, to wrap
it up here, in the subspace vn,
is the sum over l
different from k
because this inner
product only makes
sense for l different from k of
n0 l times this coefficient, 1
over Enk 1 minus Enl
1 n0 l delta H n1 k.
It's a lot of work to get here.
But actually, it's good
that we could get there.
If you even want to
write it more explicitly,
you substitute what n1 k is.
And it goes there.
Now, there is something a
little strange at first sight.
If you look at it, you
say, OK, let's see.
This is first order in
perturbation theory.
We had to go to the
second order equation.
And that's why we seem to
be counting orders wrong,
because this is first
order in perturbation.
This is another order
in perturbation.
That's second order
That's, indeed, delta
H n1 is second order.
Delta H n1 appear
to second order.
So how come we get a
first order term that
seems to depend on
second order stuff?
Maybe it's wrong
what we did in the--
we thought we were going to
get the degenerate first order
piece from the second
equation, but here this
is hitting us back.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yes.
The denominator is
also first order.
So this is second order.
This is first order.
The ratio is first order.
All is good here.
This is a good formula.
This is a real result.
So this completes our analysis
of degenerate perturbation
theory when the perturbation,
the first order perturbation,
splits all the levels.
What we're going to do now is
degenerate perturbation theory
when the first order
correction doesn't
split any of the levels.
Doesn't split them at all.
What happens?
What can we do?